alors ce qui est extraordinaire ce que
j'ai appris en lisant votre bouquin
c'est qu'au départ pendant vous répétiez
la pièce il y avait une mauvaise rumeur
dans paris c'est à dire que les
homosexuels penser que c'est une pièce
pursuit de leur gueule un peu
ouais un peu alors comme nous allons
répète en moi mois et demi tout cet été
son destin quand on répète une pièce en
général on la montre pas tout de suite
ouais et cetera donc le bruit courait
qu'on allait faire des choses un petit
peu agressive et caetera et au départ
c'était un peu difficile je sais que
dans certains restaurants je veux dire
poiret serrault n'étaient pas les
bienvenus ouais
et puis alors après miracle du théâtre
est enfin ceci étant comme jacques
charon l'énorme comédien il n'est pas
venu tout de suite il m'a mis deux mois
de cash et moi avons gagné trois ou
quatre ou six mois alors la cage aux
folles et célèbre parce qu'il était à
durée variable quoi sert qu'à des soirs
de certaines scènes qui pouvait faire
cinq minutes et d'autres soirs casemajor
on raconte c'est si vrai que entre la
pluie la séance la représentation la
plus courte et la plus longue
il y avait une heure de différence bon
c'était pas tous les jours mais c'est
parce que il y avait des improvisations
ça a duré donc ça a duré cinq ans vous
devez jouer 15 cents fois sans lassitude
au chant lassitude l'arrêt savez le
mystère du théâtre c'est que je sais
jamais moi je vous dis pas que secret
quelconque je ne sais jamais comment ça
va se passer quand je jouais repas
grosse dizaine ne sais pas si je vais
partir avec mac
je ne savais pas je me mets sur lui elle
le rail de du de l'auteur et puis il
peut être qu'il va y avoir quelque chose
un accident c'est que quelqu'un qui va
se lever dans la salle du gars mais vous
en faites pas vos gros sont des gens des
abrutis gardez vos sous
vous emmerdez pas par exemple du bas
vous avez raison et ce soir par avait
main à ma cassette je suis très heureux
jean on ne sait pas ce qui peut arriver
l'acteur qui sait ce qui va arriver est
foutu il faut pas savoir comment ça se
passe je ne sais pas et quand on joue la
cage
on savait pas comment ça allait finir
peut-être qu'elle soir je serai partie
par la part la salle en disant tu
m'emmerdes et cetera il y avait il faut
laisser cette porte ouverte à
l'invention ça c'est que cette essence
alors la cage aux folles n'a jamais été
enregistré par la télévision il cinéma
ni quatre ans c'est même pas des
français pour les italiens c'est
marcello parce que les français sont
toujours sont toujours des gens avertis
de paix ils connaissent tout
généralement et les imbéciles qui avait
à ce moment là il n'a toujours des cons
mais les imbéciles du cinéma me disait
tu comprends bien vous comprenez bien
que ce qui fait rire n'est ce pas les
spécialistes producteurs si vous pensez
bien bonjour à 8 que ce qui fait rire au
théâtre ne peut pas amuser les gens gym
qu'est ce que c'est que ça il avait
oublié que toutes les grandes comédies
américaines
c'était du théâtre était du theater
départ alors il a fallu un autre ami à
nous que tu es moins bête peut-être
qu'ils étaient italiens qui a dit moi
j'ai vu la cage dix fois ça me fait rire
autant et jean faire un film et voilà et
puis les français
alors comme il était italien et le prix
d'automne à ce niveau et il était très
mal un peu classique parce qu'il s'est
pas mis en rivalité avec vous c'est à
dire qui vous allez c'est vraiment sur
le devant la chapeau mais je pense que
c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire son
métier
il a été d'une parce que vous avez quand
on lit à deux comiques ensemble y en a
qui se prend pour le clown l'auguste et
l'autre pour le clown blanc et puis dans
la salle travail dans la tête des gens
il y en a qui se dit moi je suis le
faire valoir c'est l'autre une fait rire
avec croire et je pense que jamais ça
existe et ça c'est dit c'est pas des
choses à dire c'est pas des choses à
faire c'est pas digne de ce métier ce
qui est intéressant c'est ce qui se
passe entre poiret et serrault prêt si
ce qui se passe entre tognazzi et je
dois dire que chapeau parce que
quelqu'un que j'aimais beaucoup qui
était un inventeur formidable un
improvisateur extraordinaire qu avait du
charme et a été dans le il ne savait que
l'eau il ya forcément dans des pièces
d'aider des rôles qui sont plus
efficaces
il le savait mais il a été parfait
parfait
chapeau alors vous parlez dans votre
bouquin de l'accident qui a coûté la vie
à votre fille caroline à l'âge de 19 ans
vous dites que cela vous a rapproché de
michel audiard qui avait connu
oui le même malheur et c'est
extraordinaire dans ce bouquin enfin une
des choses extraordinaires dans ce
bouquin c'est que tous les soirs vous
alliez jouer la cage vous jouiez vous
faisait rire les gens écoutent ayant en
sortant vous écroulez dans les bras d'un
régisseur pour pleurer c'est
extraordinaire ça se trouve
écoutez moi s'il ya une chose que je
voudrais bien faire comprendre c'est que
je suis comme les hôtes ont disons que
je paie pékin pourrait peut-être pas
faire ça oui non mais je veux dire ils
peuvent souffrir les autres peuvent
souffrir mais peuvent peut-être à
l'armement bien applaudi j'étais obligé
de faire rire il oui ou non mais dans
tout dans tous les métiers ça peut te le
chef de gare le flic et gueye qui perd
sa fille le le pays
il allait même ses galons c'est le même
problème c'est la même peine mais c'est
la même peine mais vous vous étiez autre
théâtre et vous faisait rire les gens et
c'est incroyable pour pour pau pour nous
c'est encore plus incroyable laurence et
que l'après midi vous jouiez offenbach
pour la télé achat c'est plus grave est
qu un jour il ya eu la première scène à
tourner et c'était un enterrement et à
ce moment là
michel boiron vient vous voir et vous
dit michel si vous voulez renoncer
franchement je comprendrais end il m'a
dit m'a dit michel
il m'a dit on retourne à sa une autre
fois en jus d'union alors là
oui je ne sais pas moi qui suis là c'est
le personnage la wii et ne pas le jouer
n'enlèverait rien à la peine ce qui est
vrai en même temps oui j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un dirait pas son nom mais un ami
à moi qui me dit peut-être que mon
métier ma mây des ouais bah idée m'a
aidé parce que
j'étais obligé de fournir et de jouer
donc celui qui veut pas impressioner de
métro la plus petite passerelle source
ouais alors ne nous plaignons pas je
suis comme les autres mais par bonheur
peut-être que mon métier m'a aidé